have you guys been up to anything
exciting recently well i've got some
news oh
oh [ __ ] okay i've got some news um i
just want to say that uh this might be
the last podcast episode
that i do because uh if you guys saw on
twitter i've
recently been emailed by
you know you might you might know them
they're called big hit labels
they're the management of uh bts oh yeah
i know i i actually auditioned myself
yeah like yeah i remember someone signed
me up as well but uh
they they emailed me and uh it was all
caps the title was of the emails all
caps
idle casting
[Music]
and so i was like oh [ __ ] and then i saw
a big hit and i'll read the email to you
right now
because because the first time i saw
this i was like oh my god is this
actually big hit
because that'd be crazy yeah but then
the because it and
like i'll read it but like the first
half sounds legitimate it says like
hello the anime man we are big hit
labels bts's management from south korea
we are very interested in casting you to
be a member of the new boy group
in the japanese branch of our company
and this is the moment the next word i
read
i realized oh this is all a lie
japanese branch of our company std
okay okay we think you'd make us fine
yeah std we think you make a fine visual
with your astonishing idol looks
or maybe a good leader with your wisdom
in old age
if you have anyone else in mind who you
think would fit please let us know
and they gave me they gave me a list of
requirements that i needed all right so
to be up to be the leader of std okay
must speak japanese got that covered
must be six feet or over
check must be hot not sure about that
well
he's a he's a lovely oxymoron must be
somewhat feminine
must be male oh
yeah you can rock it must look good in
tight leather pants
hell yeah hell yeah and then this last
one [ __ ] killed me singing and
dancing would also be good
[Laughter]
would be good would be good kindly
consider often get back to us when
possible
but what if it was a legit big hit and
they reached out to you no because
like it wasn't no what if it was
wonderful yeah
it's like joey we want you in a van i
would 100
say yes are you kidding me do you know
how much of a [ __ ] i i i could think of
the content so think of the content
think of the stories we can tell on
trash taste i became
i became a k-pop idol for x amount of
time
how confident are you in the singing and
dancing aspects i mean dancing i'm
basically a middle-aged white man so i
can't dance to save my life i think i'm
okay at singing
but uh yeah dude could you imagine std
that would like radiate the same energy
as going to your accountant and being
like yeah do that like tax fraud thing
for me
save me all the money do all the do what
trump did dude
fix me up like that yeah
if someone actually like submitted like
an audition with my business team
like legit right to them and they
replied being like no
i think it was no or like to do the next
step or something like it was some like
verification thing and i was like right
yeah oh thanks but i've had so many i've
had like
every single dating site you can imagine
right i've had like single muslim.com be
signed up for
uh uh christianmingle.com classy
farmers only i haven't had that was that
a website yeah farmers early is like
only you have to own like a certain
amount of land to be eligible
obviously yeah you have to own like
certain amount of speakers you have to
own a certain amount of acres of
farmland
to be eligible for it and like i see
these and i don't think anything about
it but i remember that i have like an
agency looking at our emails
yeah that's when i started to get like
kind of worried about it
yeah may lean the other day goes to me
oh um
there was a weird email in your email it
apparently you had matched positive for
stds with someone
like someone you had slept with had stds
yeah
and i'm like milligan it's obviously
fake what if i thought i had an std i
would go to the [ __ ] doctor
not a website right let's just let's
just use my work email
which i know my agency checks to be like
by the way
let's get an std check right now it's
like how many
terrible decisions in a row would i have
to make to have that
like i would one have to sleep with
someone who i would have to be like well
who knows
no condom then go in think i have an std
immediately after
not go to the doctor sign up to this
website
final step use working
like do you ever meet people who are
like man i just can't seem to get a w
and then they just don't they but they
they always should do things that never
set it up yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the kind of behavior that
they do that they're like just like man
i'm just so unlucky in life and it's
like
you did drive with no wheels yeah what
did you expect to happen
i think we all know like one person that
that is like
he's like the nicest person ever yeah
just keep doing dumb stuff
come on i'm like i'm like you have to be
like no one person can take
that many l's without actually trying to
do so right
there's a lot of like sweet friends you
just like come on man i want to see you
get a w yeah
you just keep doing it man stop man
dude like that that bts one though or
the big hit labels one like i
posted it because i thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious right and it is
but uh you know i quickly learned my
lesson to uh
not [ __ ] with the keyboard you felt the
wrath of k-pop twitter yeah which
is the twitter rule i woke up in the
morning and i saw that the thing had 800
quote retweets and i was like oh
no that's never a good sign oh no boy
boy's about to get ratio
and i checked it and like a lot of them
are just you know people just saying
obviously getting that's a joke but you
know there's those handful of k-pop
stands
who were just like wow how dare you like
stereotype all k-pop stars and like i
don't worry about it
oh no no i thought it was [ __ ] good
but it's like there are some people who
are like
oh he probably photoshopped it just to
get attention i'm like what
i'm not that [ __ ] desperate for likes
on twitter that's got like more
creativity than half my videos yeah yeah
yeah that's the only reason i posted it
because i thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious
like i wouldn't have otherwise
it's it's weird that people assume that
like that's the kind of content we think
we need
yeah yeah like that's the amount of
steps that we jump into that's how
desperate i am for twitter clout
yeah that i have to fake an email the
amount of loops you would have to jump
through
to get to that point yeah i mean oh my
god you could just say i like hentai and
you get more life
dude i tweeted penis and i got like more
likes so it's just like [ __ ] whatever
yeah but um k-pop stands you don't mess
with them joey that's a universal truth